some say is the weirdest book ever
published complete with its own alphabet
and illustrations that go beyond the
imagination philosophers have pondered
its meaning code breakers have even
tried to decipher the text but the
question remains what does it mean turns
out the author lives in Italy so we went
to a studio to speak to him and try and
figure out what this book is really all
about my name is Luigi Serafini and I am
an artist the answer got a little
complicated I don't know how to explain
a few words but here's the main point is
an encyclopedia of an imaginary world
essentially an encyclopedia about a
supernatural world that reflects our own
is it in attempt to describe the
imaginary world in a systematic way it
took him a long time to create and to
follow through and half years I really
didn't know what I was doing I was like
a trance the drawings they came first
there are fish with eyes or double
rhinoceros
along with this this and so much more
the drawings were so strange that I said
had to find a language to explain those
drawings he didn't find one so he
created his own Islamic language in
other words a language without meaning
the Codex can be an experience of how to
read without knowing how to read it's
developed a cult following people try to
understand the deeper meaning the
mystery of our nature mystery of who we
are where we come from where will we go
imagination and life are almost same so
there you go
codex decipher kind of